Here I have my set of counting numbers from 1 to 7 and my even numbers between 1
and 9. We're going to write these sets inside of circles so you can better
visualize them. Here I have my set C of numbers, and here I have my set E of
numbers. I've drawn my two sets in overlapping circles, or a Venn Diagram. All
the elements of C have been placed inside this circle and all the elements of E
have been placed inside this circle. What's neat about each of these sets is we
can actually make one giant set, called the union. To find the union, we want
any element that's in set C or in set E, in any of the circles. The union is
represented by this upward U symbol, so what set do you think is C union E?
Enter your answer here.